with her hands bound the men were
marched down a hallway two americans now
in the clutches of russian soldiers who
control part of eastern ukraine
thirty-nine-year-old alexander drewkey a
retired army sergeant and
twenty-seven-year-old andy hun a retired
marine i mean they don't look bad they
look good they don't look injured so
i think that's actually quite promising
if it turns out to be real the two men
from alabama went missing june 9.
in the russian video drewke apparently
talks about their military assignment
with some help from an interrogator of
task force baguettes
they were attached to the ukrainian army
they were a recon unit prisoners can
often be forced to give information or
make false statements in videos like
these han is heard describing why he
signed up was back in america
before i left
i was
i was watching at the time a lot of
propaganda from the western side another
american fighter is also missing i have
been briefed we don't know where they
are u.s president joe biden told
reporters americans should not be
volunteering to help ukraine but i want
to reiterate
americans should not be going to ukraine
now say it again americans should not be
going to ukraine now two britons and a
moroccan have received death sentences
after pleading guilty to charges they
fought against russia in eastern ukraine
the european court of human rights has
told the russian government the
sentences should not be carried out
russian president vladimir putin didn't
mention the americans arrest during a
speech at the saint petersburg economic
forum
said everything needed to solve the
issue with the u.s government is in
place there are thousands of volunteer
foreign fighters here in ukraine from
various countries including canada
they'd also be in a vulnerable position
if captured our government has said it's
an individual decision on whether to
come here and fight